H hook is this a star crafter is this
the star crafter Huck v was it 5s H Huck
here we go
game on
um let's try D for this time those last
couple of games were efore but I guess
we're going back to e for French what's
this I can't be right
how can I be so assured so sure how can
I be so sure that that's not right let
me try to show you why
d 5 e 5 what do we have what do we have
what do we have
this is a French structure and in the
French structure guess where this pond
wants to be on C 5 but it's already
taken one move to play to C 6 my
opponent is playing a what one would
call a bad French right there's some
improvements that could certainly be
made here because C 5 is the way to be
going with this resulting central
structure with these fixed D and E pawns
for both black and white and now I have
the well I was gonna play f4 but let's
not let's not do that let me just
develop and I'm in a position to I want
to be able to respond to c5 with c3 and
I might be getting ready also for a
fishing pole type of setup here
so it's not enough to just say you know
what okay my opponent is playing like a
move behind let's say out of the French
defense still there's a lot more work
involved in fact I am questioning my
decision to play my Knight to f3 I think
it might have been better
for me to play Knight d2 to f3 and my
King Knight to e2 I could turn out to be
a better organization of the pieces well
we're gonna see let's see about that
my opponents saying thanks it's my own
system I never had any book what are you
doing are you listening to the stream
all is in the stream muted these are
being recorded by the way so if you are
new your opponent wasn't aware of that
these are recorded and you could always
go back to the videos tab and track down
this very commentary so and that's
another reason why I have that a time
located on the stream so it's it's
easier for you to track that down so a
night nights that find themselves on b3
b6 g 3 and g6
are often chased away with H pons could
be very inconvenient for those nights
that said I think this is a good idea I
think it's a good idea I get that H pine
rollin
get them rolling
so and if you do listen be very careful
I'll be very careful because I might
throw out some duds if I push the night
it's gonna go here who has a space
advantage who has a space advantage I do
what does that mean
how does me asking that question help
out with my last move or knowing the
answer to that question help out with my
last move if I have a space advantage I
do well to keep more pieces on the board
in other words if I play h5 Knight here
is going to allow more exchanges I don't
want that
if castle h5 the knight has to run to
the corner not a happy piece the night
could be kicked away any moment and I
think now is a good moment in fact I
could push forward even more and I'm
gonna do that and with this now weakened
dark squares this guy is a number one
priority hang on to this guy or you're
in big trouble hang on to that guy or
you are in a place called big trouble I
think this is my plan Bishop f4 maybe
this move is gonna be played in the
night to be making use of that square I
don't want to even allow it I'm assuming
Bishop here to get rid of my light
square Bishop I don't know if I'm all
too concerned about that let's just
support my Center hang on hang on and
now I play Queen d2 and get my bishop
here right away I like that idea
I want a knight on f6 my knight wants to
be on f6
and what else there's a lot of pressure
against this
do this watch out for beef or maybe play
B for myself
so what is the big story here before and
then this night has to worry about
finding a new home
how did what is this night doing and if
this night is okay so be three so let's
back it up back it out because we don't
like forks might be three I was aware of
that possibility but I guess I'm just
gonna have to abandon this idea of
getting rid of their dark square bishop
for the moment that's okay and get more
development and I am making way for
ninety two in fact maybe this night
wants to go on a little hike take a hike
Knight d2 f1 h to g4 does that sound
far-fetched it's a good question to ask
in your own chess games is that too far
fetch my opponents ready for night C for
Bishop takes and this guy becomes a
monster he becomes a monster that kind
no I don't even want you to go there I
don't even want you to go there
in a closed center I mean it's not super
like a super closed position there is
this open C file but in us a super
closed position you know and there
that's just that's not a correct term to
be using but you know I guess a
completely closed position where there's
absolutely no open files or half open
files this type of idea
maneuvering about D 2 F 1 H 2 G 4 you
might actually be a pretty good idea and
I don't see anything wrong with running
forward with there right now I'm not
considering castling and I like my rope
right here if anything maybe King F 1 G
2 is good my pawn is putting there's
pressure on my palm so let's chop that
guy and maybe still no I that's covered
now but this square is no longer watched
over let's go here and my other and I
could just follow in its footsteps
there we go we're about that about 50 I
brought that about 50 here 50 ticks left
you run out of time you lose unless your
opponent doesn't have mating material
okay my rook has a role of watching over
this guy maybe I could just Castle here
or not no it's gonna miss right my queen
doing something I always lend support to
my night with f4 well that's a pretty
good move I think
let's take here the Queen has to
recapture okay now there's the loss of a
pond
although night takes here as possible
maybe the Queen getting on my rook watch
over this I like my LightSquared bishop
on push is close to lethal I'm gonna try
it close to lethal check and then
discovered
there was a better continuation
somewhere okay now there's this is the
loss of the Queen we're down at time
though time is the biggest issue okay ah
good game interesting interesting
interesting so something to take away
from this is something I was already
voicing something I was already voicing
during the game here right here so the
idea to play a six and then c6 and then
D five again recognized we're in a
French structure and c5 is the move to
be played so don't go with that it's
kind of a case ecigs is played to play
d5 if you're playing C sit I mean you
could already play d5 this is what I'm
getting at it's like either do c6 to
play d5 or c6 to play d5 but don't do
both that's the quick summary right
there it's um
it's overkill it's overkill you don't
need two pawns to lend support to this
pawn on d5 so you save yourself a move
and you save yourself a lot of a
headache so g3 I played here because I
didn't want to allow Knight to h4 in
response to h5 I wanted to push my
opponent back with their night and I
really did want to get this move in and
I still had that idea I think my
opponent was needing to play this f6
move at some point and when they did I
think I end up with a nice home it was
worth a shot I did have to be careful I
do have to take into account what it is
my opponent is setting up there and with
Bishop c6 they want this diagonal to
open up knight c4 they're getting ready
for that b3 stops it recognising the key
squares and I think at this point taking
what the Queen is needed just to watch
over this point by this point we already
invested quite a bit of time we were
both low on time okay nevertheless good
game
good game that